Timothy hlma is sparking a debate after
some comments made by his agent Brian
swartstrom that's right the nepotism
conversation continues after
Charlemagne's agent claimed that the
young actor has an auditioned for a role
in over seven years yeah okay so over
the weekend xiaomi's agent shut down
reports that the actor had auditioned
for the leading role in Gladiator 2
after deadline reported that Paul Mezcal
was set to take on the role yeah
unverified reports on Twitter claim that
Austin Butler Miles Teller and Timothy
chalamet also auditioned for the role
however chalamet's agent quickly entered
the conversation to refute the Bible
rumors while revealing I know one of
these actors was shooting for a film in
the Middle East for the past several
months and he has an audition for
anything in more than seven years right
and of course if you follow Timothy
Charlemagne social media he just
finished uh shooting Doom 2. right now
Brian's tweet actually sparked a lot of
mixed reaction from fans bringing up
chalamet's industry connections so the
27 year old's uncle is Rodman flunder
while his maternal grandfather is as
writer and screenwriter Harold flender I
know his sister's on one of my favorite
shows at sex lives of college girls so
what do you think of the whole nepotism
debate and does it actually apply to hot
Timothy I'm sorry
well I know nepo babies have been a big
big thing in the media these days
especially in this industry it's easy to
I feel like for jealous people to say
that you know this person got this role
because of who they know not what they
know but at the end of the day I feel
like you have to perform no one's no
one's acting for him right and you know
after his performance in Dune it was an
amazing performance I just feel like you
have to perform if you want to get these
roles and certain people at a certain
level may not have to audition for
things but I do think that his agents
comments backfired on him here because
they didn't get the response that he was
going for yeah I mean and I'm trying to
figure out what his whole point was in
even saying that the only thing I can
think of is that he felt well if he had
auditioned for Gladiator 2 he would have
got the role but he's like listen he
wasn't even auditioning he doesn't
audition he's too busy over here so yeah
definitely backfired know you know when
it comes to whole nepotism debate I
think of people like Jamie Lee Curtis
who so beloved like you said has proven
her skill set over you know so many
years and yet her parents were famous uh
Kate Hudson Kurt Russell Goldie Hawn or
your parents and yet I don't think about
that when I think of her I just think
you know what a great actor she is but
in general and not just in the Hollywood
industry everywhere everyone always has
connections for everything
in my personal experience it's been very
rare when people didn't have like a
friend who suggested you for this job or
you knew someone here so I I think
you're right I think there's a level of
jealousy sometimes when it comes to
people talking about nepotism but it is
a real thing and it is it is tricky you
do see people kind of climb the ladder
quicker than other people who are just a
skilled if not more skilled they just
didn't have those connections so I
understand the debate not quite sure it
goes with the whole Timothy I don't know
it doesn't seem like I just think of
like when I think of nepotism babies I
think of like you know your parents had
to be like uber famous but yeah I mean
he does have people in the industry I
just think it's funny and if you're
Timothy chalamet whether you people in
the industry or not I wouldn't think
you'd audition for years because he has
he's a household name now absolutely I
mean I think his skill sets speaks for
itself yeah